well our correspondent child Stratford
is in actor Carly on Turkey's border
with Syria
so Charles Turkey saying willing and
able to take the lead now what kinds of
movements have you been seeing there on
the border well as we've been reporting
we've seen a steady troop build-up over
the last 48 hours or so certainly last
night trip back to our hotel on the road
we saw vast convoys of military vehicles
heading in this direction we're directly
on the border the town behind me
Taleb yard was taken control or by the
SDF by those Kurdish forces from ISIL in
2015 and this convoy that we saw
included APCs we believe trucks full of
ammunition flatbed trucks also carrying
tanks so this this military movement by
the Turks along this border certainly
seems to have continued as you reported
we've also heard and seen video footage
of buses carrying in Free Syrian Army
fighters now these fighters inside Syria
been supported by the Turks it's pretty
much the beginning of the revolution in
Syria they are we have come to the
understanding that they have been
stationed in a base put in a base here
in Turkey they come from the northern
Aleppo area of Syria and they will be
potentially participating in any kind of
military action into Syria military
analysts are saying that they may well
push in west of here around a town
called mumbos with the idea of
potentially joining up with Turkish
military forces further east and as
we've been reporting there are serious
concerns about the fight against ISIL in
this region what kind of ramifications
any kind of military escalation by the
Turks would have on that the SDF the
Kurdish forces across the border saying
that they cannot guarantee that they
will be able to prevent potentially
thousands of Isis prisoners escaping
jails that they control if indeed there
was some sort of military push by the
Turks
there are huge concerns of obviously
about ISIL fighters escaping and there
are concerns about territory
taking control of over recent years from
ISIL ISIL moving back into those areas
and interestingly this morning at least
the SDF released a tweet they reporting
that there were suicide attacks in the
town of Raqqa which is under their
control certainly in the early hours of
this morning so tension is certainly
mounting here the military buildup
continues and big questions as to when
or indeed if this this operation will
start and when it comes to this
potential military incursion what
options do the Kurds have now could we
see some rather unlikely alliances
forming on the other side of the border
as well there has been that reported
certainly the SDF leadership yesterday
tweeted that they were potentially
looking at the options of entering what
they described as some sort of
partnership with the Syrian regime
forces and the Russians and
interestingly in the last few hours
certainly Reuters has reported that the
Russian Foreign Minister has now said
that the Kurds should potentially reach
out to the Syrian regime obviously in
the context of this this Turkish
military buildup on the borders so yes
it seems as if alliances could start to
be moved around a little bit certainly
militarily military analysts are just
looking at the basic facts that's not
forget that if there was a military
escalation by the Turks then the SDF
could no longer rely on the kind of air
support that they saw in the battle
against ISIL from us-led coalition
forces we understand that the SDF has
over the years been trained and received
fairly basic or sophisticated but not
much of a - military equipment things
like anti-tank missiles and of course
you're looking at the largest second
largest army in NATO and that's the
Turkish forces so certainly militarily
it seems that they will be very much
outgunned but it's interesting and a
point to see how much pressure the SDF
are
and how they are now reaching out to
what can only be described as their
enemies the Syrian regime since the
revolution in Syria started all those
years ago
Charlie Stratford there in action Carly
on Turkey's border with Syria keeping an
eye on developments Thank You charlie